hey guys and welcome to episode number
25 of my road to one bill series uh yes
I do realize it's been almost a month
since the last episode so I do apologize
for that but I will explain in a second
uh the reasoning behind this uh but
first off for this episode what is it
going to consist of is a bit of my
progress and also quite a bit of the
video will be dedicated to Zora and
comparing whether I using magic only or
range in magic or hybrid is more
efficient for me uh it's kind of kind of
a case study for myself I'm kind of
interested to see because I'm not really
sure my kills are definitely slower when
I'm only using magic but I can do two
kills per trip so there's no banking
time but anyway I hope you guys enjoy
and let's get
started okay so to start off what we're
going to be doing is comparing uh the
two different ways I have been killing
zra the majority of my kills have been
uh with the blowpipe and the Trident so
a hybrid approach uh but someone did
mention that you can do it uh with Mage
only and get a bunch of kills per trip
now it seems like by using the only the
Trident of the swamps and when I Mage
gear essentially I could get two kills
per trip possibly three if I was lucky
but pretty consistently two and uh with
the other setup I can only get one so
what we're going to do is compare 10
kills of both setups and see which will
actually give me the fastest total kill
time because I won't have to spend as
much time Banking and but we'll have to
see because the kills are definitely
slower uh so we're going to be comparing
that so we'll just let that run in the
background while I explain where uh the
series have been and what's uh kind of
in store for the future uh so to start
off I about two months ago maybe three
my hands kind of started to get quite a
bit of pain uh now it's probably a
combination of well I guess a bit of it
could be from playing RuneScape a lot of
it is from my job at Costco where I'm
constantly moving things kind of doing
that pinching motion with my hand and
anyway that has kind of caused kind of
some problems for my hand so I've been
trying to not in my free time play as
many parts of the game that cause you'd
have to click a lot so it's all right it
wasn't too bad but as you can see a lot
of my content has been uh Skilling based
uh with the G only challenge coming out
that's not the reason I made the series
but it definitely was a happy
coincidence that that series did not
involve a lot of intense clicking which
is great so luckily uh it does seem to
be getting better but I'm still going to
wait a little bit until I start doing uh
hardcore run escaping and not that I
really think RuneScape is really the
main cause of it but I can't really just
not show up to work so I kind of have to
cut down on other aspects of my life
anyway so I hope you guys understand uh
in the future we are going to be trying
to get these episodes out a little bit
more frequently uh now for the plan on
this account since it's been so long I'm
still wanting to go for the mortan hard
diary so I can grind up some barrows cuz
I actually think I enjoy barrows a
little bit more not really sure why but
I I do really enjoy doing Z but I don't
really feel like it's actually that good
money for me right now because my kills
are still only like about 3 minutes on
average I have to bank I'm using
supplies I feel like if I waited until
maybe I had 85 magic 85 range maybe even
more uh The Kills might start to speed
up or maybe get void but yeah so we're
planning on going for the hard mortan
Diaries I'd also like to unlock the hard
from Nick Diaries later on uh so I can
unlock the tan leather spell mainly as
well as possibly going for the leite
Diaries down the line one other thing
I've been wondering is as I get more
Zorra kills I get more experience I get
more gold uh what gear should I
prioritize upgrading my thought process
is I should get the serpent time Helm uh
I should definitely upgrade my boots CU
all I have is Mystic boots and I'm
thinking of buying the tormented
bracelet when I have enough money
because for one I can wear it right now
and it also gives you 5% more to your
magical damage and accuracy which seems
really good uh and also my range gear I
definitely get upgrade but then I have
to take into account how many items do I
really feel like I can switch and uh is
the Tormentor bracelet going to be good
because I have to switch it out when I
use range anyway just a couple more
questions regarding that maybe you guys
have some ideas if you want to leave a
comment but yeah we're done with the
kills and now let's go see the total
times and see which one ended up being
better okay so I've successfully done 10
kills of each method one using Mage only
one using hybrid setup uh now here are
the results and they're actually a
little interesting I kind of thought the
opposite would be true of what is in
fact reality for me anyway this is based
on my not optimal levels for killing it
and just off of my own skill at it which
may or may not I would heavily swing
towards May influence this if you tried
it yourself anyway without out of the
way let's get started okay so I'm going
to start off with the hybrid zor setup
so at the start off I just recorded how
long it took me to bank after each kill
and on average it took me about a minute
and 45 seconds which definitely could be
better but that is just the number I
chose uh cuz it was reflecting how long
it really took me to do it uh so we had
to bank 10 times CU after each kill we
had to bank cuz we couldn't do two kills
with the hybrid setup cuz we took a lot
more damage and now the time spent
banking was 1,50 seconds or 17 1 12
minutes on those 10 kills uh the time
spent killing zoraa was about 2,000
seconds or 32 minutes uh for a minute
rough uh total kill time for 10 kills
not great at all but that's what it was
I didn't have any spectacular kills but
most of them were around 3 minutes on
average now for the Mage only zra uh we
only had to bank five times so we only
had to spend about well 9 Minutes
banking roughly now for the kill times
on zoraa these were not great at all and
it even included a 6 Minute kill time
which was my last one which is awful
because uh if you somehow take too long
and Jad the Jad fade shows up a second
time really can delay your kill that was
gross and terrible but the rest of them
were pretty average around 3 to 3 and A2
minutes for the Mage only cuz it
definitely takes longer so 9 minutes for
banking uh killing Zoro took 37 minutes
so about 5 minutes longer than the
hybrid setup but in total the time spent
was actually a bit less 45.7 minutes uh
for the Mage setup and only 49.7 for the
hybrid so we did it about four minutes
quicker now this is definitely not a
large enough sample size to know for
sure but I think it's going to be useful
for me and at least kind of justifies
that major only zorao at my level is
actually pretty on par with using the
hybrid setup uh based on this small
sample size okay so we're going to hop
into some Skilling now uh we just hit 50
cooking uh pretty quick we're just
cooking Tunas now the reason we're doing
this is cuz I would like to actually do
some Brewing uh it's kind of a random
subset of the game but we're going to
give it a try and we're going to go for
54 cooking for the most profitable uh
beer for now okay no clue while I'm
cooking on a fireplace here now but
anyway we're just about to hit 54
cooking and this is why we go to the
rogu um so anyway 54 cooking is going to
unlock the chef's Del light which is the
most profitable potion to brew right now
uh but yeah kind of just a random thing
I want to get out of the way but also
cooking is a requirement for some quests
I'm going to do okay so as part of the
desert treasure prerequisite I need to
finish the tourish trap quest now we're
doing desert treasure to unlock the U
extended rewards for Barrows from the
hard Diaries uh and doing two trap is
useful because you can Smith um darts
afterwards as well as getting some
experience and Agility okay so we're
just running through the underground
tunnel here we have to rescue Anna which
has dropped into a barrel somewhere and
somehow actually got locked over the
city and they wouldn't let me back in
and they kept attacking me I remember
this being an issue last time too so I'm
not sure what that was about all right
so we can now Smith s which is actually
going to be pretty useful later on uh
actually profitable smithing experience
I think okay I think we're just
finishing up the quest here and what
we're going to obviously put this
experience in is agility 100% we're at
61 agility right now so that's 4.6k
agility experience and another 4.6k
agility experience we're putting right
in there so it's almost 10K that we
won't have to get manually which is
probably going to save us like 40
minutes really uh but yeah there's the
tour trap quest complete okay so to
actually do desert treasure do need to
get my thi level up uh which I think may
have been the initial reason for why I
stopped playing this account we just hit
40 thie and we need like 50 plus I don't
know 54 or something for Desert treasure
it's not super low but I guess assume we
can do blackjacking which would be kind
of good and I think Temple of iov is one
of the last quests we have to do for the
uh prerequisite for Desert treasure it's
a pretty easy Quest and gives about 10K
range experience in the boots of
lightness which is useful okay so I went
and grab the ice arrows I hope I got
enough I only got like like 15 of them
but we do have AIS accumulator so I
think we should be fine we just have to
kill what's this guy called again the
fire warrior of the zorak and last up we
just have to kill Lucian we decided to
go this route because it didn't seem
like there's any difference uh taking
the other way and this was actually
easier there we go Quest completed we
just killed Lucian and that is going to
give us 10,000 range experience and
8,000 Fletching experience which I think
is actually got us a Fletching level uh
yes it did 67 Fletching and 10K range
experience is always is nice and I think
that's all the quests we need for Desert
treasure okay so we decided to do
another five steing levels by pick
boxing guards it's a little bit quicker
than Master farmers and we have been
using the dodgy necklace which is
increasing our experience hour a bit
although they break really quickly so I
have to get used to using them but if we
successfully pickpocket this guy one
more time that should be 45 uh thieving
and now we can move on to blackjacking I
think uh yeah 45 we're good another
pretty slow skill is agility but we are
about to hit one more agility level so
that's going to be 62 and we'll just
need four more levels uh for the hard
morania diary as well as if we wanted to
boost for the Zorra shortcut we could do
that as well but yeah we're on our way
to 70 so one last thing I want to do
before I ended the episode for today was
uh sell off all my Zora loot as well as
a bunch of stuff in my bank and just see
how much money I have and maybe we could
actually afford a Tor bracelet I don't
know we'll have to see okay so about 4.8
mil from the Zora loot we also put about
1.5 mil in the Trident to refill it and
in total we have 7.3 mil so I don't know
if we have enough but let's see what we
have in the bank okay this is a bunch of
stuff I found which is going to bring
our cash T up to 10 mil the uh tormento
bracelet is about 15.8 mil right now so
we're going to have to stretch I think
we have some extra Cannon pieces and
some RAR seeds and some stuff we can
probably liquidate even more okay we're
digging down pretty deep here but we're
I think getting pretty close now I think
I'm just going to go ahead and buy it
cuz that's 15 mil I think we just need
another 700k for the torture amulet or
sorry the tormento bracelet yeah 800
more K okay we have it open here on G
tracker so it looks like 15.7 mil as of
the current price which is uh not too
bad I guess so we need another 700k
though okay we're selling off the good
old dragon Jane body you guys were
flaming me for that anyway so let's get
rid of it and go ahead and buy a
tormented bracelet I'm pretty excited to
give this a try it's going to increase
our Max hit by at least one maybe two
and we'll try buying it for 16 mil and
this is going to be the first real gear
upgrade I've had in a while now after
this I definitely want to upgrade my
boots as well as uh get a better helmet
and in general maybe get a ring of
suffering couple other things but yeah
our gear is coming together now we just
need some more levels but yeah looks
like it increases our Magic by plus S as
well as a magic damage boost by 5% so uh
yeah hope you guys enjoyed the video
sorry again for how long it took for
this episode to come out I'm going to
try to get them out uh every week or two
going forward and yeah thanks for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next episode
[Music]